[Music]
uh we got a new
new video here from our
deep state operative that we have does
he have to capitalize every letter
yes it's like the title of a book he
choose your own adventure mom has my
sister call cops on me for talking back
over their skinhead son beating me in
dresses
like it's a wordy title i get it
so it's well it's actually the series
that's what it's called it's like game
of thrones the whole series is called
mom has sister call cops on me for
talking back over their skinheads and
beating me in dresses it's a bit wordy
though
yeah i didn't work on that yeah uh
better ending in the game of thrones
though hopefully
uh this is uh dayton hypernova he's he
makes his videos but he caught on
to to not putting him on youtube because
you know he found some people were
goofing on him
some people were goofing it's not nice
guys so then what happened was you
started putting them unlisted and
posting
other places because that works here it
is
let's watch this new one his op sack is
garbage
i'm about to get on the stairs to ask my
mom if i can
buy some more materials for
an art display
and if you like that starts next week
imagine
indulging this [ __ ] but we the last
video we watched they were yelling at
him and then
he's still asking for an art display
you're in your 30s why are you doing an
art display
but it's like i know artists that
they understand that they're not going
to sustain themselves on that they get a
job
they do they do you know what i mean
like i knew artists in tampa that like
literal painting artists that
would still have to work you know what i
mean and then it'd be like you know
shows were like art shows where their
[ __ ] got sold they might make a few
bucks
this [ __ ] is he wants to pay he
wants free room on board
he wants money for his materials he
wants health burritos he wants free
pizzas and he never sees anything wrong
with it i hate him and he wants to ride
a seat to see christina reaching i hate
this person
or if i can spend a little bit of money
on that
while i'm starving below minimum wage
working for her
bingo card make sure you're hitting your
bingo card
if i were sherman i would [ __ ] this dude
up daily yeah you would have to be no
yeah okay he beats the beating me in
this house daily would be a truthful
thing if you lived with me
i'm not sure if you can hear me very
well on this because my voice is very
hoarse right now
um but yeah i
have an art display that starts next
week
and i it's for my fashion stuff but i
don't know if i should say that much
because she's
my mom and she hates wearing dresses
like nobody here
turns in here like clothes or display
next week that i need
some more supplies for
so i asked her if i could invest in some
art supplies
um it's not an investment it is
no no that's not an investment yeah it's
an investment
while i'm starving below minimum wage
working for i heard you we heard you two
we heard you we heard you oh
oh there's a reason we're playing this
video it starts off like this but
there's another confrontation
rage dude i feel nothing but rage i was
here
that i was asked to do
by some people who are trying to help me
make money to move out
because it's all fashion so
watch undercover time
sherman undercover by the way we can all
agree right that
the wood grain toilet seats are just
gross yeah they're great they'll they
gross you out
yeah get a splinter not only that but
like
wood or even fake wood fiber how about
before i want to be clean
it absorbs bacteria and and germ like
you want
yeah porcelain that you can wipe with a
very nice
bleach space thing like oh i always get
skeeved out by that
washing his hands real quick and then
he's going undercover
[Music]
tonight on take news nine undercover
dayton hypernova goes he even sounds
like a news guest
dayton hypernova goes undercover to
catch his brother beating him
here we go here we go
hey mom i have uh talking to his mom
an art display that i'm supposed to do
next week
but i need more supplies for it um
it's a halloween type of game it's just
no street also can i just
ask a question here because this idiot
when you have an art exhibit coming up
it's usually for paintings you've
already made
yes this idiot just wants attention and
wants to be like
i'll do the art i want to do an art
thing i want to do this art thing
oh [ __ ] i got to come up with some art
he's the only god i hate this man
i need to get more supplies for now
and why and i need to order them
he's asking his mom for money of course
i guess you have to give me the
information
i guess you'll have to give me the
information
and when are you gonna show dad so he
can use that thing for free
huh i can do that yeah i need to
do a no no here's here's how that should
work
here's how that should work well what
about that thing you said you're gonna
do for your dad
all right you know what you're right
fair enough i'm gonna go do that right
now
right and when i get that done then
we'll do the
art supply thing everything with this
piece of [ __ ] it's always like yeah yeah
i'll do it i'll do it
yeah it's fine yeah yeah yeah
but he never does anything and then
you're like you see
like it's so frustrating but then he's
gonna melt down when they don't give him
his [ __ ] health burritos oh he does
i need to buy that stuff sooner rather
than later because
it starts on tuesday i need to buy that
stuff
sooner rather than later you're a
30-something year old doing an art
display have to give me the information
of what you need i mean i'm just going
to buy
stuff on ebay so i don't know you'll
have to give me the information and i'll
buy it girl that's the
so here's what's happening remember she
took his credit card away
uh because i guess he had a credit card
with so he wants her to just give him a
credit card to have free rein to buy
whatever he wants
she's saying show me what you want to
buy and i'll get it for you even though
she shouldn't be by the way
she shouldn't even be doing that however
she's being nice
right but it ain't going to be good
enough as he needs that cash
and money get a list of stuff and write
it down so i know
well i have to learn tonight okay what i
probably should wear them tonight okay
all right just give me the information
and i'll order them
no well can you be present while i order
the card because apparently this is
not as bad as me getting beat the
weekend of my birthday oh this again
so he went to ask for something she
didn't even say no
she said give me the list i'll get it
for you he wants the card and
immediately
first off you getting beat by your
brother doesn't mean your mom needs to
buy you stuff
one thing has nothing to do with the
other he's so hateable
you know i didn't get anything for my
birthday this year you
i'll tell you what you got for your
birthday this year you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] got free room and board
you got a hundred dollars a week you get
left relatively alone you don't even get
held to the
obligations you have it's a pretty sweet
[ __ ] yeah
and none of that's good enough
i should at least be able to get a few
items that
should put this so i can make some money
on my own
that's not minimum wage i think get a
real job
wait so are you saying this is a loan
yeah
and the this this art display is
supposed to make him money so you're
going to pay back the money that you
made no
he doesn't have any concept of no
oh whatever you're gonna say no you but
it's it's like just he's he's completely
disconnected
from everything
we spent all that money you did it was
last year
it was last year and then i got beat
down the weekend of my birthday when as
i turned 33
all of that was before that moment 33
yeah weekend of his 33rd birthday
i need a present he's acting like this
at 33 yes
everything that you bought last year
that was with my money
and then the last part of last year that
was all agreed
that the last part of that was birthday
christmas stuff because i kept getting
beat
down and that's reasonable then i got
beat down again and we haven't discussed
it
since then i got beat nothing but
disgusting beat down
that's the only thing you talk about
dayton literally all you'll talk about
in front of both of you and i'm not
trying to discuss about this i just want
to buy a few supplies
and you're the one making this a problem
i don't want to make sure
look she's being wholly unreasonable
here i need like 200 bucks
all right well you need to find some art
supplies for some stuff on it's
some stuff i just said give me a list
and i'll order for you
just give me money not just if you give
me a lot of money
though i've i got beat up a few times in
my life royce
i deserve that because you were a fan
artist
i've been beaten up before okay did i do
it
okay then i don't owe you any money
that's not how this works no no
even if i did i don't owe you any money
depending on how bad the beating is
depending if lawyers
i hate him so much
by yourself it'd be hilarious if this
ends with his mom [ __ ] roundhouse
kicking him in the face
they need to just put him in place and
shut the doors
and leave him there wooden doors he
needs to go to
a place where they put these kind of
people because he's not well
and it's he might as well if people are
gonna have to deal with this [ __ ]
they might as well get paid for it
yes agreed
i need to buy this tonight can i use a
credit card no
no you cannot you believe that it is
more dangerous for me to have your
credit card than
for him to beat me ah there it is a guy
[ __ ] hate him he is trying to compare
having her credit card
to being did have nothing to do with
each other is this what you're kind
of sitting down that's fine i'm not
going to take any more than what i need
to do right
tonight the weirdest part about this
stuff mike is that then he
it's not just he records his stuff right
then he uploads it
like he's right oh yeah he's convinced
you can't trust the person getting
beat down in front of you in your house
this is outside by the way he walked
outside so now the whole neighborhood is
hearing this
i will do that oh dad showed up
[ __ ] ignorant where where in this
bible does it talk about getting
beat old testament
like a lot like a lot in the old
testament
uh right after thou shalt not give your
son who's [ __ ] your credit card
that's right in that section
son who's a skin head i will say it
i think sherman's just bald yeah he is
he has we've seen sherman
i've seen sherman and he's just a bald
guy
i get it hey i'm gonna be there with you
sherm i'm not knocking you
but clearly not a skinhead no i just
need a few supplies
and if she's gonna give me a proven i
will keep you
i will keep proving yes you will that's
why we won't give you
credit you're on camera oh good you're
on
camera he's carrying children in the
camera
in camera's view he's carrying your
inventory
you can't really send the children do
you ever shut up
don't listen that's why it's always
about this
man beats me and you're going to know me
forget it
we forget it do not buy him any [ __ ]
now he's at it now you get nothing you
know what he's like remember that
episode of south park
where cartman wanted the ipad and his
mom goes oh we can't get you that honey
we'll get you the samsung one instead
and he freaked out
in the store and he's like you should at
least buy me dinner before you
[ __ ] me mom and then she didn't buy him
anything
you're a child that's what you are you
don't get anything now
she shouldn't have said yes to begin
with no and you shouldn't be
like he's so dependent on them that
that's he's got one option
mom give me your credit card no hey
what a great life you've built for
yourself
paradoxes cipher cipher
dating rope oh yeah you are dad
you get beat down you gotta get angry
you're [ __ ]
yes you would you should like
no i'm not dating because you're 78
years old
78 year old man
this is a guy that like i know i [ __ ] on
boomers all the time right
but there is a certain degree of
boomerism that's acceptable
where you get your kids through school
right they go on they have lives
and then you get to enjoy your twilight
years in a nice quiet home
with your wife who you barely speak to
and it's nice and quiet and i know i
don't know why i always have reference
egg salad sandwiches with this old man i
just she just looks but
he would enjoy that yeah a fresh salad
sandwich he put cilantro in it yeah and
he just likes to have his little
his glass of lemonade and barely speak
to his wife and just sit in the backyard
and go
hey honey you know the uh the pear tree
is coming in real good this year
yep and that's the extent of his
conversation for the day
and he just wants to chill you know what
i mean and now it's like
nope no one no i'm not dead the [ __ ]
trace jesus crucified at 33 i got beat
down do you see something
look did you did
did you hear what he just said you
should learn
because you are 78 years old no one no
i'm not
dead the [ __ ] christ jesus is
crucified at 33 i got beat down do you
see some [ __ ] parallels
he thinks he's jesus jesus got crucified
at 33 and he got beat down at 33.
do you see some parallels
he thinks he is equivalent to jesus
christ
well equivalent to jesus christ
now you won't you know why it's not like
jesus christ by 33 jesus christ was
the [ __ ] out of the house his parents
and sherman are the money changers
jesus was a carpenter he had a job
no you're slobbering slobbering [ __ ] you
do it do it do it right now in front of
your neighbors
i don't think the neighbors would care i
think that neighbors would be
first off telling the police yeah i
didn't see anything i don't know you're
talking i think that that old man could
probably beat you to death and the
neighbors would go yeah he attacked the
poor old man
and then they'd bury you and then all
the neighbors would come over and bring
a casserole
and go thank [ __ ] that old asshole's
gone it's always about this
man beats me and you're gonna know beats
[ __ ] what if he beats dayton to
[ __ ]
death right she beats him to death refer
to all the neighbors and then like
everything magically he's fish sherman's
alcoholism goes everything yeah you're
right he moves out he beca
becomes a small business man opens up
one of those ifixit stores
you know sherman starts doing all right
you're like the whole neighborhood's
changed
trees that were dead for years have come
back to life very weird it's like
pleasant pleasantville yeah
get it we forget it do not buy
him any [ __ ] that is so unreasonable
yeah
dad you get beat down you gonna get
angry
yes you would you should learn
because you are 78 years old no one no
i'm not
dead the [ __ ] christ jesus was
crucified at 33 i got beat down do you
see some [ __ ] parallels you know
you're slobbering
[ __ ] you now i wonder what he did to him
there because it sounds like his dad
with him was going after him
this is your slobbering i kind of feel
like he must have not it sounds like he
knocks something out of his dad's hand
yeah it sounds is that what it sounds
like something yeah
do it do it do it right now in front of
your neighbors
do it
it's so [ __ ] up it's so [ __ ] up
manhandled by my father is he doing
foley work
as he's being trying to yeah why is he
banging on oil drums
is this how he's banging on an old
55-gallon drum yeah it's very odd
i'll call the police and they'll come
and get you something sounds like
somebody's playing
uh like penn station drums yeah
oh i'm in a dress
i'll call the police tell them to come
and get you all right you're on camera
right now come get me yeah
good okay you're on here so call the cop
you're on camera right now you knocked
the rain barrel over
you happy where's joe biden gonna put
his switchblades
they're on camera right now oh oh
the big reveal they were being recorded
the whole time
let's see these vicious animals this is
all because i need
support a few supplies online and you
doesn't tell me you can't [ __ ]
stop he never stop like i
you'd kill him right like yeah you have
to murder somebody at that point yeah
i'm an honorable person i don't beat
people
i've seen you i've seen you hit people
you hit you hit sherman with a wine
glass i've seen you hit
every member of your family at some
point
you are beating me i'm not you are
beating us so he did hit him
so he did hit them not beating you
why you're gaslighting right now dad
he's gaslighting
words and then they just use them and
they have no idea what they mean
you are gaslighting hey addie
do you want to call the police for me
and tell them that earl that
it's okay she she it's all on camera
addy's a sister
right now it's on camera to mom
she's calling
that's so bad you need help
that is so bad you look how calm they're
still being you need help
you they shouldn't be this calm though
like
it just goes to show you how worn down
they are and they're like
you're just being bad you know
at some point i just look it's it's
obviously
very easy to make fun of him and all
that stuff but
the police at what point the police have
been showing up a couple times he's
recorded them at what point are they
actually going to do something like
they have to i'm afraid and i mean this
seriously like i'm afraid that
if he's already pushing them hitting him
he'll do something crazy like
those are old this guy's 78 years old
old people like in their sleep to
smother them like i'm really worried
about that
not even as a joke like the guy is
insane he's an insane person
who should be in a padded room
you can help a lot more than you're
helping you can help a lot more
he's a skinhead who beats me you're
going to call the cops on the person
again b
yes no yeah i mean they're going to be
like what
wait what he's not even here yes
if the cops are here you gotta be in
deep [ __ ] they're gonna be in deep [ __ ]
like they were
he really is that dude why would why
would they be in deep [ __ ]
no
are you running away earl oh sherman
just shut up
dad he ran away oh that was great that
was sherman walking in okay hold on
if the cops are here you gotta be in
deep [ __ ] that was sherman
now
there's that that's chairman that is
sherman that is sherman
there he is there he is another fighter
has entered the battery
awful
[ __ ] gaslighting family you beat me
you're twice my size
he is really scared of sherman though
you see how he runs away oh yeah he's
terrified the problem is i don't think
sherman just goes out of his way to beat
this guy he just
doesn't take his [ __ ] yeah of course
probably just smacks him in his [ __ ]
mouth and he's no
[ __ ] out of my hands oh yeah guys it's a
skinhead who beats me they're calling
calls because i yelled back at them or
whatever because
their temperament is is ridiculous
yeah that tape's really going to serve
well to show how crazy your parents are
they're insane
[Laughter]
he is a [ __ ] lunatic man he needs to
be removed from that house
and i do look i will agree that the
parents should be evicting him by now
right like
you can't keep this person in there
after he hits you after he steals your
[ __ ] and still try to buy him art
supplies stop making excuses for him
i know you're his parents i know you
think you're supposed to love him but
some people just don't deserve the love